this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan's taking a look at
some of the weapons he hasn't yet
checked out from battlefield 4. this is
a really interesting firearm the an-94
it will fire the first two rounds at 1
800 rounds per minute which is just
unheard of for a rifle and it's
unworkable for a rifle unless you have a
hyperburst design like this if you want
to see our previous episodes on
battlefield 4 make sure to check them
out we've got handy links down in the
description of this video to take you
right there and make sure to subscribe
as well as we've got tons of content
just like this on the channel including
loadout a show we take a look at the
history and impact of some of the most
iconic weapons in gaming we collaborated
with jonathan on loadout too so he'll be
making a fair few appearances over on
that show as well right let's take a
look at the guns of battlefield 4.
so another
recent addition to the modern firearm
lineup and certainly to the british
army's inventory what we see in the clip
and what i'm holding in my hands most of
which is the l115
now this is um
this is in bits because it's a trials
rifle that has been shot to death but
one of the the real benefits of the
collection that we have here
is that we are essentially blessed that
when sometimes when things are done with
on a trial we end up with them which is
tremendous we were lucky to get this so
this is really more of a museum piece so
what's the difference between the the
115 and the l96 various detail
improvements learned over time um i
guess one of which would be the folding
stock so big chunk of this one is
missing you can see the skeleton
underneath but some something that was
sort of relearned for afghanistan i
guess was that you don't want a folding
stock to shoot a sniper rifle obviously
but having a folding stock to pack one
up transport it around get in and out of
vehicles and helicopters that kind of
thing
is
super helpful basic action is the same
design that ai are famous for that was
in the l96 but critically this is a
derivative of the arctic warfare magnum
rather than the basic version so it's a
lengthened strengthened receiver and
that and the heavy barrel are because
this thing is for the 338 lapra magnum
at the end of the day gameplay-wise it's
a bolt-action rifle but you do get a
representation of the potency of that
338 cartridge it's kind of a perfect mix
of precision potentially smaller
calibers and
size of bullet ability to deliver
payloads
or different ammunition types
armor-piercing
even explo explosive incendiary that
kind of thing it's big enough to do that
without the
weight bulk
recoil of 50 bmg it's much more of a
true sniper rifle than really any of the
50 bmg sniper or anti-materiel rifles
the russian pp2000 this is one of a
number of russian designs for submachine
guns and it's it's distinctive it's
fun to use in the game the the rate of
fire is surprisingly slow
from what we know of how it works i
haven't had my hands on one of these
things it's a closed bolt straight
blowback design so there's nothing
locking the bolt shut or even delaying
it as it comes back and the bolts quite
small it's quite light so you'd expect
it to go rattling back and forth at i
don't know eight nine hundred rounds per
minute thousand rounds per minute but in
reality it's more like six six fifty
rounds per minute which is what we see
in the game luckily for game developers
there are lots of youtube videos around
of rare or rare in your country types
that you can at least get a good
estimate of how they're supposed to work
or how they look when they work we we
have we are very lacking in modern
russian firearms in the collection for
various reasons i won't bore you all
with we'd love to get hold of one of
these there are two different forms of
stock incidentally there's the folding
stock depicted in the game and there's
an extended magazine that you can either
put in the gun for more bullets
or you can stick in the back of the gun
as a sort of not very good shoulder
stock which is the only time i think
i've ever seen a magazine used as a
shoulder stock
next up the iwi
galil the ace or ace uh for those of you
that don't know this is a last 10 years
or so this is a
an attempt to keep the galil
system current the big change being to
the lower receiver to give it somewhat
more modern ergonomics a bit closer to
something like the ar-15 but it is a
little hamstrung by its ak lineage and
this is a derivative
i would say of the kalashnikov so the
developers have modeled the dust cover
so it's got a sprung dust cover that
moves up and down on the left side
because one of the important changes is
a left side cocking handle so to fit
with modern drills modern manual of arms
where you keep your firing hand on the
pistol grip and you use your left hand
for all of the operation you can now do
that
on this version problem with that is
that you're opening up the other side of
the weapon to dirt and debris the sprung
dust cover should keep a lot of that out
and of course you've got an integrated
full-length rail on the top which is
great in the real world and great in
gaming for you to put on whatever
unlocked optic you want essentially
despite all my talk about the variance
and derivatives it allows you to do a
semi-futuristic take on an ak but not as
advanced looking as the aek so it it
fits the battlefield roster quite nicely
and it's something we're going to be
seeing in contemporary warfare for a
long time both the ak generically and
the galil specifically probably the ace
is going to take off to the point where
you'll see more of those around than you
will the legacy
galil's
this is a nice one the fn fnc in its
bofors ak-5c
form lowercase k by the way so this is
not some nod to the weapon having ak
lineage it doesn't it's just that aptoma
kalashnikova in russian gives you ak
letters ak automatic carbine in swedish
gives you ak from a
parallel route and we do have
an ak-5
in the collection same receiver same
barrel for the for the full length
barrel version bearing in mind we're
looking at the fight ak5c in the game
but what we're also seeing in the game
is the
improved variant like any other nation
that's had combat experience in the last
20 years sweden has
modernized its rifle it hasn't stayed
still there's no reason to let that hold
you back in terms of improvements to the
handguard to the upper receiver to the
butt stock for a more ergonomic fit in
the shoulder you see the improved
version of the ak-5c buttstock in the
game there those are all product
improvements if you like to the basic
rifle and carbine so this is a case of a
legacy
rifle carbine
being kept relevant into the present day
and we're seeing it's it's um virtual
version if you like at its heart this
thing is absolutely fine it's reliable
it's accurate it's five five six the
ergonomics were also already pretty
great um inspired by the ar15 the only
real downfall i guess is the
ak style fixed cocking handle on the
right hand side that you can't really
overcome
without some serious architectural
changes but you train you train around
it and on this weapon it's sufficiently
close to the top of the weapon that
all you got to do is count it over
slightly not to the extent of the sa-80
and it's a big old knurled cocking
handle and you just grab it and you [ __ ]
it that way not really a drawback and
this thing is still soldering on
this is a really interesting firearm the
an-94 now this
was supposed to be
the replacement for the ak-74
in the russian
armed forces in the 1990s and like a lot
of um russian small arms design they
were they were really trying to push the
envelope and trying to get the next
level of small arms this thing was
classified for
issue and has seen issue if you hunt
around you might just find photos of
russian special forces actually carrying
this thing but very few ended up being
made why well it sort of was a leap
forward but not enough of one for the
for the cost and complexity what's the
jump it's the hyper burst that we do see
a representation of in the clip
so it's effectively
a gun inside a gun it's it's a chassis
uh with the stock on it and the trigger
mechanism it's
almost impossible to simulate without
being able to fire and this one doesn't
fire but uh what we've got here is a
recoiling
rifle mechanism a a self-loading rifle
mechanism that is gas operated that
moves back
and allows you it fires the second shot
as it's coming back for this hyper burst
mode it will fire the first two rounds
at 1
800 rounds per minute which is just
unheard of for a rifle and it's
unworkable for a rifle unless you have a
hyperburst design like this where the
recoil of those two shots is only felt
by the shooter once this gun within a
gun has
reached the back of the receiver so it's
firing so fast that you don't feel the
recoil of the working parts until it's
fire it's done this double firing cycle
this is also why the magazine is offset
to one side
because there's a there's a
cartridge
conveyor in here that needs the room on
this side of the gun to operate and
that's why the magazine is canted off to
one side which gives it an even more
exotic
look we've got this what uh 1800 rounds
per minute hyper burst mode and then in
full auto and the way we see it in
battlefield 4 rather than firing the
first two rounds at 1800 rounds and
cycling down to 600 rounds per minute it
just magically runs on 600 rounds per
minute which isn't quite how this works
due to the mechanical insanity that's
going on inside but yeah a really
fascinating design and a rare example of
a effectively a prototype getting
adopted and then reality hitting home
and the russian army just sticks with
what it's got
i think one of the good things about the
battlefield or some of the battlefield
games is the you do get a variety in
terms of the you know western versus
eastern if you like design aesthetic and
just a range of different guns so one of
those is the the ots 14 groza which in
real life comes in
different calibers the version we see
here which is as you can tell from the
magazines and the description in the
game is 762 by 39 standard ak round and
it which makes it a sort of sort of
bullpup ak it's it's not uh too far off
although this is a bullpup with it with
a shortened overall length it does also
still have quite a short barrel so i
think i think there are only two 762 by
39 weapons in battlefield 4 one being
the sks with a somewhat longer barrel
that is
semi-automatic only so you've got
reduced rate of fire but higher damage
and then there's the groza which
mirroring in real life has a shorter
barrel reduced muzzle velocity reduced
penetration as a result of that so
there's some justifications in in both
the real world and in the game for
which you would choose one is compact
and has a
moderately high rate of fire the other
is slower and bit more accurate but in
real life you wouldn't choose an sks
over a groza you'd go with an ak
pkp it's an excellent weapon in in the
game i remember from my my time playing
so the pkp is a pkm with a heavier
barrel so when we say heavier barrel we
mean literally heavier thicker which can
take more in the way of heat before you
have to give it a rest essentially or
replace it but in this case the although
the passion egg barrel is replaceable
it's not designed for carrying a spare
barrel in the field which is how the pkm
is supposed to be used you're supposed
to use that heavier
thicker barrel for sustained fire at
close quarters out to medium range so
it's a really it's a dedicated light
machine gun variant of the pkm whereas
the pkm is designed to be used on a
tripod or as a light machine gun as well
as the thicker steel of the barrel it
also has a cooling jacket with so that
the handle on the top that's part of a
forced air cooling system which works
like the lewis gun in that the muzzle
blast draws cold air from behind and to
the side
over the barrel to help cool it so
that's interesting and then minor
details such as a permanently attached
bipod whereas the pkm bipod is designed
to be quickly removed for fitting the
gun to a tripod or
whatever whatever you use so yeah it's
it's effective and respected in the
military world and i think it is in the
battlefield world as well
if you'd like to check out the royal
armouries youtube channel i'm on that as
well we've also got links in the
description for ways that you can help
out the museum in these slightly tricky
times if you can definitely come and
visit us we've got three sites in the uk
if you get the chance they're all worth
a look
[Music]
you